as we know role model is isn't work as
much as it works in other places role
models and immunities have some problems
and such as social values such as
religions such as a structure of the
communities like Islam a day as you know
Middle East has you know is how many
religions Islam Judaism Christianity and
other religions it's a kind of problem
for success in role models and also
countries in the Middle East have many
problems to plan economic plans such as
role models and they are they are very
problem in social issues there they have
tribes in their country you see many
tribes in one country that they can't
use and they can't plan economy your
plans for the future I think it is a
problem but it is not completely
problematic thing for the countries with
the going of the time we have we can
have role models for our future and we
can success it what not it is far away
from here and we have a line trying to
plan such plans in your country and do
it in the best way